SENAT
♪
>> AFGHANISTAN IS SPINNING OUT
OF CONTROL.
>> DOCUMENTS BEING SHREDDED HOW
ARE THINGS BEING SECURED.
>> WE ARE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
DEMOCRATIC PRESENCE ON THE
GROUND IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT WE ARE REDUCING THE SIZE OF
OUR CIVILIAN FOOTPRINT GIVEN THE
EVOLVING SECURITY SITUATION
THERE.
>> AFGHANISTAN IS HIGHEST NUMBER
DOCUMENTED CIVILIAN CASUALTIES
IN A SINGLE YEAR SINCE U.S.
RECORDS BEGAN.
>> THESE SOLDIERS AND MARINES
FULLY KITTED OUT PUTTING ON
NIGHT VISION GOGGLES LANDING IN
KABUL TAKING POSITIONS IN
AIRPORT THEY ARE GOING TO A
COMBAT ZONE, ARE THEY NOT.
>> THEY ARE CERTAINLY GOING INTO
HARMS WAY LUCAS.
>> LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
MOLLIE MOLLIE HEMMINGWAYWAY AT
THE FEDERALIST.
CHARLES LANE OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND STEVE
HAYES EDITOR OF THE DISPATCH.
WELCOME TO YOU ALL.
ONE MONTH AGO TODAY, MOLLIE NOT
TODAY BUT ONE MONTH AGO MAYBE A
FEW DAYS AFTER THAT, IT SEEMS
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IT WAS
HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT THE TALIBAN
WOULD TAKE OVER IN AFGHANISTAN
TODAY CONGRESSMAN MARK GREEN OF
TENNESSEE ALSO AN AFGHAN VET HE
SAID THIS, WATCH.
>> THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THIS SURPRISED THEM.
THEY WERE NOT EXPECTING THIS NO
YOU BEEN IN COMING WAS BRIEFED
THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY GOT CAUGHT WITH THEIR
PANTSDOWN NO OUTCOME HAS TO BE
INEVITABLE HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO SPECULATE ABOUT
SURPRISE.
WATCHING THIS LIKE YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS IT SURE APPEARED
TO BE A SURPRISE, MOLLIE, YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> THE PUNDITS AND MEDIA AND
POLITICIANS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE INCOMPETENCE OF THE EXIT OR
HOW SURPRISED THEY ARE ABOUT
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT THEY SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
THIS IS THE NATURAL RESULT OF 20
YEARS OF FAILED STRATEGY.
THEY SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
INCOMPETENCE OF THE STRATEGY
THAT THIS COUNTRY USED FOR TWO
DECADES.
WE WENT FROM USING OUR MILITARY
TO FIGHT AND WIN WARS INTO THE
IMPOSSIBLE TASK OF NATION
BUILDING.
WHEN WE WERE ATTACKED ON 9/11 WE
NEEDED TO HAVE A SWIFT AND
SERIOUS RESPONSE.
WE DID THAT BUT THEN PRESIDENT
BUSH TOOK HIS EYES OFF THE BALL.
WE GOT MIRED IN THE IRAQ WAR HE
AND ANTHONY AND BIDEN TOOK ON
THIS TASK OF NATION BUILDING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE COUNTRY HISTORIANS CALL THE
GRAVEYARD OF EMPERORS.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO FOCUS
ON SO WE NEVER DO IT AGAIN.
WHEN OUR MILITARY IS USED CLEAR
STRATEGIC OBJECTIVES GET IN AND
GET OUT.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT BUT IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT LESSON TO LEARN RIGHT
NOW.
>> Trace: SHE MAKES A GOOD
POINT, STEVE.
THE IDEA REALLY WAS AFTER 9/11
YOU GO IN AND ATTACK THE PEOPLE
A TACKED YOU AND THEN IT WAS
ABOUT DEMOCRACY BUILDING
HOPEFULLY THEIR THOUGHT WAS THAT
WAS GOING TO STOP AL-QAEDA FROM
COMING IN.
20 YEARS LATER THE DOOR IS OPEN
FOR CARBON MONOXIDE TO COME BACK
IN, STEVE, YOUR THOUGHTS IT.
SURE DOES.
CARBON MONOXIDE NEVER LEFT
AFGHANISTAN.
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A BIG
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE OVERALL
STRATEGY.
I THINK THERE ARE PLENTY OF WAYS
IN WHICH THE STRATEGY IN
AFGHANISTAN FAILED OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES.
BUT IT DEFINITELY MATTERS.
IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
SURPRISED, BY THE SWIFTNESS OF
THE TALIBAN ADVANCE.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE HAD
STATEMENTS FROM BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS IN
RECENT DAYS THAT ARE VERY CLOSE
TO BAGHDAD BOB TERRITORY.
YOU HAD NED PRICE YOU PLAYED A
CLIP OF HIM A MOMENT AGO SAYING
LAST WEEK THAT THE TALIBAN
WANTED DURABLE SOLUTION THROUGH
NEGOTIATION.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
THAT THE TALIBAN WANT A DURABLE
SOLUTION THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS.
YOU HAVE HAD OTHER SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE UNITED STATES
WOULD THREATEN TO ISOLATE THE
TALIBAN IF IT TAKES AFGHANISTAN
BY FORCE.
THE TALIBAN ISN'T WORRIED ABOUT
BEING ISOLATED AND BY THE WAY,
AS THIS IS ALL UNFOLDING, THE
TALIBAN CAN LOOK NEXT DOOR TO
IRAN, WHICH IS THE WORLD'S
GREATEST STATE SPONSOR OF THAI,
CONTINUING TO CONDUCT ATTACKS
AGAINST AMERICANS AND OUR
INTEREST.
AND WE'RE NOT ISOLATING IRAN, WE
ARE INVITING IRAN TO BE PART OF
THE WORLD COMMUNITY.
SO, THE ARGUMENTS THAT YOU ARE
GETTING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SUGGEST THAT THEY
WERE SURPRISED BY THIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE SO INCOHERENT.
>> Trace: IT'S NOT FAIR TO SAY,
CHUCK, THAT JOHN KIRBY WOULDN'T
USE THE WORD COMBAT BUT, BOY, HE
WAS REALLY HESITANT.
I WANT TO WATCH THIS BACK AND
FORTH WITH HE AND LUCAS
TOMLINSON AND GET YOUR RESPONSE.
>> DO YOU CONSIDER THIS A COMBAT
MISSION?
>> THIS IS A VERY NARROWLY
FOCUSED MISSION OF SAFEGUARDING
THE ORDERLY REDUCTION OF
CIVILIAN PERSONNEL OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
>> MARINES AND THE SOLDIERS
STRAPPING ON GOING TO KABUL THIS
ISN'T COMBAT?
>> LUCAS, LUCAS, WHAT I'M
TELLING YOU IS AND I HAVE SAID
IT BEFORE THEY WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> Trace: TRYING TO FLY
CIVILIANS, CHUCK WHAT USED TO BE
KABUL INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT,
RIGHT THE TALIBAN IS MAYBE HOURS
OR DAYS AWAY FROM TEEFERG.
IT SURE LOOKS LIKE THIS COULD
BECOME A COMBAT ADMISSION IT
OKAY A GREAT QUESTION NO ONE
KNOWS THE ANSWER TO.
WHAT IS MORE IN THE TALIBAN'S
INTEREST TO STAND BACK A WHILE
AND LET THE AMERICANS GO
PEACEFULLY SO THEY DON'T RISK
RETALIATION FROM THESE VERY
CAPABLE U.S. TROOPS OR ENGAGE
THEM AND BLOODY THEM AND ENGAGE
THEM FURTHER AND MAKE THINGS
MORE DIFFICULT FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT MOLLIE
SAID WITH HER SECOND GUESSING
AND SO FORTH OF THIS MISSION.
AND FOCUS ON TODAY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TODAY WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY WHETHER YOU LIKE
IT OR NOT WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THERE OR NOT, IS THAT
THOUSANDS, MAYBE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO DEPENDED
ON US ARE NOW LEFT HIGH AND DRY
AND EXPOSED TO TREMENDOUS
POTENTIAL REPRISALS AND VIOLENCE
AT THE HANDS OF THIS EXTREME
ISLAMIST GROUP.
NUMBER ONE, AND NUMBER TWO,
ALLIES ALL OVER THE WORLD,
JAPAN, KOREA, THE MIDDLE EAST,
LATIN AMERICA ARE ALL ASKING
THEMSELVES TODAY ARE WE GOING TO
END UP LIKE THESE FOLKS IN
KABUL?
MAYBE HIGHLY IMPERFECT AND SO
FORTH BUT PUT THEIR TRUST IN THE
UNITED STATES AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY ONE FINE DAY THE
PRESIDENT SAID CONTRARY TO THE
ADVICE OF MY MILITARY ADVISERS
WHO TELL ME THAT WITH JUST 2500
TROOPS WE CAN MAKE A GO OF IT,
WE ARE LEAVING.
>> Trace: MOLLIE, YOU CAN
RESPOND TO THAT THESE PEOPLE,
THESE INTERPRETERS, THESE PEOPLE
WHO WE DEPENDED ON FOR YEARS
NEED TO GET OUT, WE'RE TRYING
RIGHT NOW TO GET THEM OUT.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT THE
PENTAGON DID NOT MAKE GOOD EXIT
PLANS IN PART BECAUSE THEY WERE
TRYING TO TRICK PRESIDENT BIDEN
INTO STAYING THERE.
THAT'S WHAT OUR PENTAGON HAS
DONE.
THAT IS HOW THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP PEOPLE THERE BUT THE
FACT IS THAT RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON WHAT'S IN THE
TALIBAN'S INTEREST, WE NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS IN OUR
INTEREST.
IT IS NOT IN OUR INTEREST TO
SPEND TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, 20
YEARS AND ALL OF THE LIVES THAT
WE LOST FOR A MISSION THAT
COULDN'T EVEN BE SUSTAINED FOR A
FEW DAYS WITHOUT THAT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT.
>> Trace: HERE WE GO QUICKLY
WINNERS AND LOSERS.
STEVE?
>> MY WINNER ARE AIR CONDITIONER
REPAIR MEN WITH NEARLY HALF OF
THE COUNTRY UNDER EXCESSIVE HEAT
WATCH.
THEY HAVE BEEN AWFULLY BUSY
LATELY AND I THINK ARE MAKING
BIG BUCKS.
MY LOSER IS DAVID MYCHALSON THE
HEAD OF THE LEFT LEANING FACT
CHECKER SNOPES.
PLAGIARISM CAPITAL OFFENSE
PEOPLE COULD RECOVER FROM IT NOW
HE SHOULD BE MORE THAN SUSPENDED
IN MY VIEW.
>> Trace: CHUCK?
>> MY WINNER IS THE STATE OF
TEXAS AND REPUBLICANS WHO
CURRENTLY RUN IT.
THEY ARE GOING TO PICK UP --
THEY ARE CONFIRMED TO PICK UP
TWO SEATS IN THE HOUSE PER THE
CENSUS THAT CAME OUT THIS WEEK.
AND CALL ME CAPTAIN OBVIOUS BUT
MY LOSER THIS WEEK IS ANDREW
CUOMO FORMER, SOON-TO-BE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK FORCED TO
RESIGN OVER THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CASE.
>> Trace: HE DID RESIGN?
MOLLIE, YOU LAST?
>> MY WINNER ARE PARENTS TAKING
ON SCHOOL BOARDS PUSHING BAD
IDEAS SUCH AS CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND OTHER RACIST IDEAS ON
THEIR CHILDREN.
MY LOSER SECRETARY MAYORKAS WHO
IS OVERSEEING THE HUMANITARIAN
DISASTER AT THE BORDE